hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play lumber island
another indie game coming at you that
was recommended by many of you guys and
many of my fellow let's players it's
made on the Unity engine and just is in
very very early beta as you can see it's
version 0.1 so let's get into it there's
a teddy bear seems to be common theme oh
I'm playing I seem to be some sort of
asthmatic person in a boat pick up my
flashlight here I'm in a boat but I have
the unfortunate problem of oh hello what
thought okay I picked up a phone of some
sort and I seem to be trapped in the
middle of the ocean I don't know how
this helps me or how I got here I'm
supposing that's part of the mystery I'm
sinking I am sinking why am i sinking
hey hi this is not of it we're good okay
I have have I wait where am i oh okay
there we go I crash-landed on some sort
of an island with really low gravity so
created by dean forage thank you for
this amazing unity it actually does look
pretty good I mean compared to some of
the indie games I play there's got a lot
of working in I mean Rock I don't know
if anything's custom textures in here
but there's plenty of obvious work hey
mr. crow what are you doin here there's
a lot of obvious work and attention to
details which is really important in
these sort of games and I do appreciate
that so we're gonna follow the path and
not try to get too led astray
hopefully oh hello oh look it's a
haunted bungalow let's go inside see
what's what it's locked
well what the hell hello do I want to go
in there anyway I suppose not okay since
the path continued anywhere else it does
not but hang on what is this hello oh it
seems to be a whole side ripped off of
that house there I don't exactly know
how its standing up but I guess I can
you can I jump on these rocks nope okay
into the woods we go can i sprint i
can't sprint that's interesting this is
like one of the first games where the
sprint function has been disabled but
enjoying the environment mmm
I can smell the trees the grass okay
enough silliness let's take this one a
bit more seriously all right so we're
obviously looking for some sort of a key
although I don't know where it is and
I'm whoa hello
what we got here another haunted
bungalow this one seems a bit more
decrepit than the other one but it
looked hello there's a fire over there
hang on I'll go get that in just a
second don't know why it's called lumber
Island except for maybe in the past it
was used as like a lumber a lumber
location of some sort hang on how do I
get in here can I open the door some Oh
what wow what have I done oh oh it's got
that bug where the mouse is outside the
game here's a door here sorry about that
but we're fine now yeah I can't click
because for some reason um on some
things that's overlooked in these indie
games is when people play in windowed
mode because it's easier to rob Wow Wow
yo are you a lumberjack holy balls look
at you you're so big and strong oh okay
let's hit those with fire and stay away
from that guy we say your teddy bear
that I saw in the beginning of the main
menu haha well I know I can't sprint now
because he's so slow this was your teddy
bear I bet this with your camp I have
your daddy bear noony noony noony
okay I'm at gate D teddy bear with me
come on Teddy we're going leave this guy
behind if that's custom music it's
really good hahaha so what am I supposed
to do about this what am I supposed to
do about the giant axe wielding murderer
that's trying to well murder me
I've got his bear so maybe I can hold
his bear ransom maybe there's something
in that building that I missed but I was
kind of oh hello what is this a trail of
flowers to some wood here but what's the
point of that where is he I know I'm
gonna turn around and these guys are
gonna be there although hopefully I'll
hear him hi
look at the size of you you know you
don't have a care in the world there
buddy
man that is loud I got the volume turned
up again hi
I'll have your daddy bear what are you
gonna do about it you big baby your big
baby
big whiny baby maybe taunting the
monster isn't the best solution but I
don't care
you should your big whiny baby just baby
one is bottle a bunch of teddy bear I'm
gonna rip your Teddy's head off Oh what
you gonna do about that that's why I
thought that's what I thought
all right there's more to this island
but I think I'm about to explore the
remainder of it I'm kind of reaching the
edges of the precipice
and precipice into my own destruction I
don't know what else is to this place
this is a teddy bear icky maybe this is
only version point one so I don't know
if there's anything actually here nope I
don't see anything I'm gonna guess that
that's pretty much it for now I have no
idea I should probably do more research
about these games before I just start
playing them cuz I mean I think there's
gotta be something right right I'll dive
headfirst into the new was this is this
a different place or is this the same
one this is the same one as before and I
can't get in it still the teddy bear is
not a key huh let me go try to find me
man can I go up this hill here
maybe barely yes no uh close but no
cigar where are you oh okay ah here we
go I can go up this hill here okay wait
a minute no oh this was a camp I was
here like two seconds ago what's up
what did wait what I did inspect that
actually do anything the hell alright so
there's nothing here on this camp I just
I just moved the teddy bear from the
side of the camp to the chair what did
that do did that do anything did it
unlock the door maybe in some strange
rip dualistic fashion okay the music
just looped okay that's what that was in
some strange way no music oh no it's
back okay I don't know what so confuse
I'm so confused
maybe it unlocked it I don't know I
don't know no it did not
what is going on here I know
Duncan views and I know that little
Billy is gonna be pummeling through the
woods any moment now I'm gonna try no
it's got turn and he's gonna be right
there he's somewhere he's somewhere he's
somewhere you're gonna corner me in this
building that I'm gonna go in again cuz
he's a son of a [ __ ] I have Riya oh
here we go what is this ah they came
again now with the threats I don't know
how much longer I can hold out but I'll
never sell my land okay can you put that
down now it would be lovely if you could
put that down thank you I want it back
yeah but I don't want it cuz we got a
giant lumbering monster that's about to
rip us in half where is he anyway okay I
found a journal but oh hi you're stuck
ah ha you're stuck ha ha ha ha you're
not stuck you're kind of stuck are you
stuck you're not stuck man saw why it's
called lumber island cuz this giant
lumberjack here decided not to sell his
land we look at daddy's good cuz he's
got special animations that um Oh what's
called kinetic response I forget his
legs move to the changing of the terrain
that's really cool effect that probably
goes unnoticed in a lot of games
especially horror games cuz you'd be
running away from home too scared I
don't know what's going on so I'm just
gonna let him kill me ah my body is
right
oh I the letter I don't I don't know it
I don't know what's going on I don't
know I don't know how to beat this I'm
gonna made this yeah I don't know I'm at
a loss there's got to be someone else
right
there's got to be hang on let me zoom
forward into the future just to not
waste you guys it's time to meet
wandering around the island with nothing
do I'm a zoom poured into the future and
if I see something you guys need to see
I will let you know so today bad tell me
your secrets were my doing no no no aah
aah holy balls you're faster now but the
hell you're not supposed to be faster
why are you faster not good what the
hell go away I don't want any go away
what the hell huh I still don't know
what I'm told to do maybe I'm supposed
to get him to bash down the door I don't
know I don't know what I'm supposed to
do guys I don't know I don't know la ah
he's quick he's quick like bunny look at
him go nice animations I don't know i'ma
go steal your teddy again I'm on chop
off its head and see how you like it
maybe I'll lure him up here maybe that's
what he needs he just needs a good time
out in the fire come on come on come on
what you got what you got what you got
huh no Bob Bob Bob Bob dead ok I don't
know huh I don't know I'm obviously
missing something horribly because I'm
incredibly stupid
I'm incredibly stupid when it comes to
these games so you guys need to hold my
hand and let me know if there's anything
that I missed so thank you all so much
for watching click the in the day
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
my turn
bye-bye
right
by
right